jean pierre raffarin est avec nous pour
ce premier preuves par 3 de l'entre-deux
tours des élections municipales bonsoir
bonsoir mercruiser merci d'être ici avec
nous et demain nous recevrons le
ministre chargé des relations avec le
parlement
alain vidalies c'est donc pour ce rendez
vous public sénat agence france presse
dailymotion et avec mes consoeurs nadège
paul jacques de la fp et puis perrine
tarneaud de public sénat
bien entouré nous sommes bien entourés
quelle chance nous avons jean pierre
raffarin comme premier ministre vous
avez connu les revers des élections
intermédiaires comme l'ont dit pour vous
les régionales de 2004 donc on a très
envie de connaître ce que vous prenez
aujourd'hui même si le ps espère bien
sûr toujours dimanche atténuée pour le
moins la gifle électorale subie lors du
premier tour comme responsable de
l'opposition
vous prenez ceux de vos amis qui voit
l'ump renaître ne vous y trompez pas ce
n'est pas qu'ils nous veulent c'est
qu'ils ne veulent plus la gauche
avez vous déclaré vous avez l'occasion
très bien informé absolument vous
l'avais dit dans l'enceinte du bureau
politique de l'ump vous y reviendrez
dans un instant on va parler d'abord de
l'issue qui peut s'offrir selon vous à
françois hollande que peut-il ou que
doit-il faire selon vous alors qu'on
annonce sa prise de parole à l'issue du
second tour
il faut qu'il parle qu'il parle est vite
parce que au fond les français sont dans
une situation de grande inquiétude
notre situation économique et sociale
est d'une extrême gravité et ces
élections exprime la déception le
désenchantement et ils demandent un
changement politique le président doit
annoncer ce changement de ligne
politique et les français demandent à ce
qu'on s'occupe du chômage est ce qu'on
s'occupe des impôts pour les baisser à
ce qu'on s'occupe de la délinquance pour
la limiter et au total on voit que le
gouvernement a l'air intéressé par
d'autres affaires d'autres sujets que
les sujets essentiels des français donc
le président va devoir parler va devoir
rassurer
parce que s'il ne mesure pas que les
français attendent une nouvelle
orientation ça ne fera que s'aggraver
alors la nouvelle orientation
apparemment tout est déjà bien tracé
jean pierre raffarin on a l'impression
que l'agenda est fixé pour l'après
municipal il ya le pacte de
responsabilité
et puis le rendez vous avec les 50
milliards d'économies exigés par
bruxelles enfin deux heures on peut pas
dévié de cela on nous en parle depuis
des mois passage à l'acte le problème
aujourd'hui avec ce gouvernement c'est
qu'on roman d'action le 14 janvier dans
sa conférence de presse le président de
la république a dit des choses plutôt
raisonnable une politique de nos films
centaines de livres trio fille de 3 mois
0 double zéro et donc comment voulez
vous que les français puissent être
satisfait de cette situation de
quelqu'un qui a un moment dit bas
pendant deux ans j'ai pas fait une très
bonne politique je la change et puis
rien ne se passe déception et puis
dimanche soir un premier ministre qui
était mal entendants et on voit
visiblement ils n'écoutaient pas à les
français on a un gouvernement mal
gouvernants malentendants qui t'offre on
n'écoute pas et donc les français vont
se dire dimanche prochain on met la
target qu'est ce que vous auriez voulu
qu'il dise jean marc ayrault qu'il se
fasse hara kiri del sûr du tout qu'il
quitte 10 ou moins qu'il a entendu le
message du ras-le-bol des françaises et
des français sur le fait que personne
n'a l'air de s'intéresser au problème
numéro un quel choc il a évoqué les
impatiences et il aurait dû parler des
colères mais je pense qu'il aurait dû
être plus branché vous savez ce
qu'aujourd'hui - c'est à lui de choisir
parce que s'il est sanctionné dimanche
prochain ma foi ce sera son problème
c'est pas le nôtre nous a dans
l'opposition on constate les choses
c'est que aujourd'hui il y a dans le
pays une grande volonté que les
socialistes arrêtent leur politique
échange de carlos qu'il faut donc
d'abord changer de premier ministre
ça ça regarde le président il faut
changer de nouveau il faut une nouvelle
politique et donc c'est au président de
choisir une politique nouvelle
personnalité pour l'incarner d'une
manière générale mais ça c'est une
responsabilité présidentielle c'est pas
l'opposition de décider cela donc nous
nous disons nouveau cap et probablement
qu'il faut un nouveau premier ministre
pour incarner ce nouveau cas robin
paiement mais ça c'est la responsabilité
expérience je le disais jamais la farine
l'une des possibilités toujours offerte
au chef de l'état dans toutes les
circonstances similaires c'est d'user
fonction usé le premier ministre
jusqu'au bout et c'est une opportunité
encore valable pour vous selon
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que par rapport
aux situations que j'ai pu connaître
nous sommes dans une situation dans une
situation de plus grande gravité
aujourd'hui il ya une forme de
désespérance dans le pays
on a des problèmes sociaux qui sont
majeurs on a une immigration mal
maîtrisée avec des problèmes dans un
grand nombre de quartiers aujourd'hui
qui inquiète les français
on a une situation d'impôt qui a écrasé
la classe moyenne et on a une situation
de chômage qui n'est toujours pas
inverser ça fait deux ans que prétend la
république s'est engagé sur cette
inversion de la courbe du chômage
et rien ne bouge donc les français sont
déçus demande une nouvelle politique
sans doute qu'il faudra incarner cette
nouvelle politique
c'est au président de la république de
le dire mais s'il ne mesure pas s'ils
n'entendent pas que la colère gronde et
que la colère peut un jour se
transformer en révolte si on ne la
comprend pas je pense que vraiment il y
à une situation alors dans ce
gouvernement qui est une invitation de
manhattan avant le chef de l'état l'a
entendu puisqu'il a abrégé sa présence à
l'est au sommet international des
grandes puissances est une il faut quand
même autre chose qu'un changement de
programme 1 va falloir quand même il
faut dire en train d'entrer à paris pour
réfléchir à priori concernés quelques
heures pleines oui mais pensez-vous de
prospection qui étaient là et enfin cela
je pense que tout ceci révol révèle une
certaine 2
à mon avis une certaine fièvre des akan
inquiétudes dans la république
aujourd'hui je vois qu'un certain nombre
de ministres sont très nerveux donc il
ya de la nervosité dans l'air je pense
qu'il faut être serein calme et
responsable ce cru mais les françaises
c'est une autre politique que ils ne
veulent pas qu'on l'ait qu'on abandonne
les problèmes économiques et sociaux
pour se diviser les français sur les
problèmes sociétaux dont ils ne veulent
pas qu'on ressorte comme programme
l'antisarkozysme ça fait deux ans que la
ferme du cas nicolas sarkozy a été
réglée par les français par une élection
qu'on refasse aujourd'hui de l'anti
sarkozysme comme un thème de campagne
les français ne souhaitent pas ce genre
de choses ils veulent qu'on leur parle
emploi sécurité et sur les sujets
pourtant quel est selon vous le meilleur
profil aujourd'hui pour incarner une
nouvelle politique à matignon on a
beaucoup évoqué manuel valls claude
bartolone est candidat quasiment déclaré
on évoque également le retour de laurent
fabius à côté franchement c'est pas
l'opposition derrière le casting que
vous avez des commentaires
c'est normal moi je pense que il est
clair que ce gouvernement manque
d'expérience donc plus on prendre à
quelqu'un d'expérimenté plus le
président wade sécurité donc ça c'est
c'est le point important le président a
besoin de sécurité
j'imagine que le président de la
république aujourd'hui ce sens dans une
sorte de climat d'insécurité vis-à-vis
de son gouvernement et donc il a besoin
d'expérience de solidité sans doute
moins de meinier sans doute plus de
cohérence et sans doute une incarnation
du discours politique générale nouveau
kim et l'emploi au coeur des stratégies
c'est à dire une politique qui parle aux
entreprises qui remet de la confiance
dans l'économie
parce que sans confiance y aura pas
d'investissements il y aura pas
d'emplois donc aujourd'hui ce que
doivent faire un nouveau gouvernement
s'est créé la relation de confiance avec
les entreprises qu'on arrête de désigner
les entreprises comme des adversaires
que la finance c'est l'ennemi et que
dans un certain nombre de discours qui
ont été tenus contre l'économie tout
ceci est assez désespérant il faut
redonner confiance à nos acteurs
économiques c'est ça l'enjeu alors le
mais le gage de l'expérience aujourd'hui
apparemment pas réciter ce serait
laurent fabius vous seriez surpris de le
voir revenir à matignon je ferai après
je ne serais pas surpris il a la
dimension c'est quelqu'un de respecté
donc et c'est quelqu'un de respectable
donc c'est quelqu'un qui précède même
aujourd'hui au quai d'orsay
depuis ce cas y avait un certain nombre
de preuves donc ce ne sont pas des gens
ce type de profil sont pas des profils
ni les génies incompris par là on n'a
pas encore vu vraiment de résultats on
n'a pas encore vu vraiment une puissance
à l'action on a vu un talent de
communication on n'a pas encore vu les
preuves de l'action donc ça c'est au
président de la république de gérer ces
paris alors il ya des moments où il ya
des moments où le président de la
république peut faire des paris j'ai le
sentiment maintenant qu'il est plutôt un
peu dos au mur et qu'il ferait mieux de
ne pas faire trop de paris et de jouer
la sécurité parce que la situation du
pays est extraordinairement instable je
vous assure que dans ces élections
municipales je n'en reviens pas on a vu
moi j'étais chez moi un des buts est
battu à député suppléant battu un autre
député qui gagnait d'habitude au premier
tour qu'avec 20 points de retard par
rapport à dernière fois donc il ya un
mécontentement très important et donc y
compris dans la majorité il ya un vrai
blues chez les socialistes alors je
pense que je finis les aventures
maintenant de la sécurité des gens
d'expérience et de compétences pour
mettre en oeuvre une politique qui a été
définie comme une politique de l'offre
c'est-à-dire une rue mythique de
l'investissement et l'emploi on ne vous
sentez pas un peu en solidarité avec
jean marc ayrault vous savez ce que
c'est le premier ministre bouc émissaire
ça y est là des coups moi ça plombe le
velayat s'il va pleuvoir du côté de bien
sûr non mais je pense qu'il n'a pas il
n'a pas tous les torts le premier
ministre c'est une organisation qui
naturellement concerne aussi les tâches
du dessus le président de la république
quel étage du dessous les ministres que
le premier ministre n'est pas le seul en
cause naturellement mais lui même quand
il était dans l'opposition était
suffisamment sévère pour qu'on se
permette quelques libertés à son égard
j'ai quelques souvenirs donc ça cela dit
je respecte la personne
il est engagé à fond dans une tâche est
extrêmement difficile
je crois qu'il n'a pas l'équipe qu'il
souhaitait avoir et qu'il n'a pas
forcément les gens sur lesquels il peut
s'appuyer comme il le souhaiterait et
puis aussi sans doute que
les orientations étaient pas
suffisamment clair ce pacte de
responsabilité il ya tout là dedans le
14 janvier c'est plutôt bien accueilli
c'est plutôt une orientation positive en
changement premiers sont incompris il
faut aussi que le président se remanie
lui-même peu plus de décision et moins
de concertation je pense que quand il y
adeux l'indécision au sommet on peut pas
demander ensuite à toutes les équipes
d'être au top de leur performance dont
je pense que l'exécutif c'est un
ensemble
on voit bien qu'aujourd'hui ça ne marche
pas valéry giscard d'estaing avait dit
ça un propos après quelques mois de
mitterrand le socialisme ça ne marche
pas eh bien il faut que le le président
de la république puisse se dire que le
socialiste ça ne marche pas et donc il
faut faire autre chose aujourd'hui c'est
ce que vous vouliez françois hollande
toujours en piste pour 2017
le président de la république dans son
camp est toujours en pis la fonction
présidentielle de la vème république
fait que c'est une fonction très forte
moi je ne crois pas que quelqu'un puis
est ce qu'un de candidat contre un
président sortant
et quand on m'avait dit en 97 après la
dissolution que jacques chirac ne serait
pas le candidat de 2002 je souriais
parce que j'étais persuadé que si
jacques chirac voulait il serait le
candidat parce que la fonction
présidentielle s'impose dans la vème
république
donc à mon avis il n'ya pas de place
dans le camp du président contre le
président mais donc à mon avis il sera
candidat sera-t-il élu ça fait vendre
ça dépendra des circonstances est ce que
des 1900 très loin les choses ne se
passaient beaucoup tu peut se passer des
choses des villes gérées par le front
national ça vous inquiète jean pierre
raffarin
ce qui m'inquiète un peu c'est toute
cette campagne sur cette semaine sur le
la place ducale front national dimanche
et a eu des élus savez vous combien
d'élus du front national cinq cent 500
combien une élue du modem 6 ans combien
d'élus de l'ump milliers 80000 donc on a
500 élus du front national et on a 80
mille élus de l'ump et on fait du front
national la question qui domine le tout
c'est la troisième force politique
aujourd'hui jean pierre raffarin elle
sera la première aux élections
européennes on masseube sûr du tout
c'est pas sûr du tout je ne le crois pas
et en tout cas si elle est la troisième
force c'est en grande partie à cause du
socialisme
il est même très souvent la deuxième
force parce qu'elle est devant les
socialistes et on l'a vu dans des
élections législatives où le socialiste
est éliminé par le front national c'est
à dire le scénario de monsieur jospin en
2002 qui n'a même pas accès au second
tour je note quand même il ya une
corrélation entre les échecs du
socialisme et la montée du front
national et donc cercle front national
est un sujet grave
certes c'est important de faire en sorte
que l'on limite son influence dans le
pays
mais d'autre part en faire le sujet
majeur de la vie politique française non
le sujet majeur
aujourd'hui il faut pas croire que les
gens ont pour le front national une
attirance extraordinaire ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure pour l'ump c'est
vrai pour le front national
les gens voter d'abord contre le ps de
18 heures c'est qu'on sanctions s'était
félicité vous avez vous avez les gens
ont voté contre le ps
quelquefois ils votent contre le ps avec
une extrême colère il boit trop et ils
votent contre le ps avec plus de
modération il vote ump
mais au fond il va le voté contre le ps
et l'information du pays aujourd'hui
c'est qu'on a des gouvernants qui sont
rejetés et c'est ça la gravité on a une
situation sociale grave et un
gouvernement faible c'est sale p tite
question en marge de 2 du front national
à marseille jean-claude gaudin a créé la
surprise à elle est partie manifestement
pour un quatrième mandat mais il a quand
même passé un accord avec une candidate
guérini strzelecki ses pelles lisette
narducci dans un secteur qui était
détenue par monsieur guérini
l'ajustement le front national qui avait
voilà
voilà l'alliance contre contre nature
jean paul ii a eu fait la surprise oui
il a fait la surprise pour des
observateurs qui ne connaissent pas jean
claude bonnal et non comme moi j'ai vu
qu'on attaque et jean claude gaudin sur
saône âge je me suis dit ils vont
réveiller le lion c'est à lyon qui sait
se battre
c'est un faux qui aiment ça lille qui a
fait beaucoup de choses pour sa ville et
s'est engagé dans cette campagne avec
ardeur
quand vous pensez qu'à des sondages il
ya des commentateurs politiques y avait
pas seulement il y avait des
commentateurs qui donnait la ministre
dans l'arrondissement de monsieur gilles
côte à côte à lui
et là il avait plusieurs plus d'une
dizaine de points d'avance et donc on
est dans une situation où il ya beaucoup
de décalages entre l'observation et la
réalité la réalité c'est que godin
efforts à marseille qu'il a beaucoup
travaillée à marseille et ça se voit
dans les séries arrivent à signer un
accord avec une grille nice
je ne sais pas si ce que vous dites je
n'ai pas vu je ne pense pas dans ce
deuxième secteur mais coûte peut-être
que je sais pas si c'est exact
en tout cas ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que jean claude gaudin dans la
position dans laquelle il est il a pas
besoin d'accords la preuve c'est que il
est largement en tête et qui va gagner
dimanche qui va gagner qui va être belle
fête et je pense que les socialistes
sont gravement trompé en pensant caché
lors des fêtes locales par une victoire
qui aurait été la compensation idéal
marseille et bien ils vont échoué sur
toute la ligne
alors ça il le mérite alors donc vous
avait prévenu lors du bureau politique
de l'ump au lendemain du premier tour
ne vous y trompez pas ce n'est pas que
les électeurs nouvelle c'est qu'ils ne
veulent plus de la gauche vous l'avez
effectivement souligné il ya un instant
alors élu ump plus bénéficiaires
finalement que vainqueur jusque là on en
parle avec nadège cula jacques de la fp
qui nous rejoint juste après ces
éléments d analyse avec samia de sheer
on la disait affaibli par les scandales
l'ump a finalement pris sa revanche sur
la vague rose de 2008 ni la ferme mais
lyon ni les soupçons de trafic
d'influencé qui pèsent sur nicolas
sarkozy n'ont fait fuir son électorat
dimanche au premier tour des municipales
la droite a récolté plus de 46% des voix
objectif atteint pour le parti de jean
françois copé lui-même réélu dès le
premier tour dans sa ville de meaux
l'ump et le premier lieu le premier
réceptacle de ce vote sanction
grâce au travail de reconstruction
entrepris par notre famille politique
depuis deux ans une victoire grâce aussi
et surtout à la colère et l'abstention
des électeurs de gauche
la victoire de l'ump me paraît très
nette
même si elle se fait largement par
défaut elle tient à la sueur abstention
des électeurs de gauche obtient à
l'affaiblissement prononcé parfois
spectaculaire comme à quimper ou à
grenoble du parti socialiste mais malgré
tout elle se traduira par la conquête de
nombreuses villes 1 me en valence quand
quimper la gauche pourrait perdre de
nombreuses municipalités
mais à droite on se garde de crier
victoire trop vite
il est hors de question de faire preuve
du moindre triomphalisme il faut au
contraire rester très mobilisés
mobilisés car au second tour on annonce
plus de 200 triangulaire avec le front
national
une situation qui profite davantage à la
gauche la vraie inconnue est plutôt le
comportement des électeurs du front
national certains ont voté au premier
tour pour s'opposer au maximum à la
gauche au pouvoir
est-ce que parmi ceux ci certains se
diront finalement que en sopo en
maintenant leur vote les favorise les
victoires locales la gauche et donc
reviennent à l'ump c'est possible ce
n'est pas du tout certain pour
transformer sa victoire avec bleu l'ump
dépend donc largement des voix du front
national
l'autre grand vainqueur de ce premier
tour voilà un adage que jack est avec
nous donc monsieur raffarin
vous connaissez votre consoeur de l'aef
est bien sûr un certain temps elle
vieillit beaucoup moins vite que moi
je vous remercie beaucoup monsieur
raffin je vais tâcher d'être à la
hauteur et écouter on a entendu tout à
l'heure monsieur copé qu'il disait l'ump
a été le réceptacle 1 des votes mais
vous vous avez dit aussi comme le
rappelait michel tout à l'heure a
conscience c'est le ps qui a perdu
autrement dit c'est pas nous qui l'avons
gagnée qu'est ce que vous avez voulu
dire exactement je pense qu'il faut pas
de triomphalisme il faut pas se tromper
sur deezer monsieur copé voilà on est
d'accord c'était la conclusion de notre
bureau politique ont dit très clairement
que nous avons engagé un travail de
reconstruction nous avons est construit
ce réceptacle du mécontentement mais de
là à ce qu'on nous confie les
responsabilités du pays
le travail n'est pas achevé et donc sur
notre projet sur notre union sur
l'ensemble de notre organisation nous
avons encore du travail à faire et donc
je voulais pas simplement que parce que
ces résultats sont très importants ils
sont plus importants quand ils attendent
et nous mêmes on a vu des dizaines et
des dizaines de chefs lieux de canton
bascule et est donc dans la france très
profonde
le résultat est encore plus
impressionnant que vu de par la france
d'en bas mais dans la france d'en bas
vraiment il ya un désamour des français
pour la socialiste devrait plus
important que ce que vous imaginez voilà
exactement et donc dans ce contexte là
je ne voudrais pas que l'ump considère
que c'est son seul mérite est que
maintenant ça y est je pense que dans le
jugement des français il y à un certain
nombre de choses qui nous concernent et
que nous ne sommes pas innocent de la
situation dans laquelle elles pays
complètement
il est clair que les socialistes sont
particulièrement maladroit et ont pris
les mauvaises orientations
je pense que nous aussi nous devons
améliorer notre gouvernance pour
l'avenir et donc on doit continuer à
travailler continuer à préparer notre
projet pour l'alternance répondent aux
préoccupations des français nous opposer
certes mais aussi proposé est donc dans
ce travail là je ne voudrais pas qu'on
se satisfassent de 7 victoires en 10 ans
maintenant c'est pour nous parce que ça
ça veut dire que on peut gagner mais
peut-on gouvernement partis a dit
justement qu'il avait ligne
on se responsabilité d'incarner une
espérance est-ce que vous avez les
moyens de vos ambitions
oui je pense qu'on est quand on est
capable aujourd'hui d'incarner
l'espérance mais la grande question
c'est le passage à l'action aujourd'hui
face aux difficultés économiques et
sociales et donc c'est du gouvernement
que le pays attend les réponses et donc
il faut pas que l'opposition se mettent
dans la vème république
au niveau de l'exécutif nous serons face
à l'exécutif dans la dernière phase de
l'élection présidentielle mais
aujourd'hui pour les français c'est on
est pour ou on est contre l'exécutif on
est pour on est content le gouvernement
et ce qu'ils ont répondu dimanche c'est
on est contre le gouvernement ils ont
pas dit vive l'ump ils ont dit on est
contre le gouvernement donc être contre
le gouvernement ça veut dire que des
choses sont positives de notre point vue
dans l'orientation politique on doit
mener mais on a encore beaucoup de
travail donc sa pige pas mieux
d'ailleurs vise les sondés sont pas les
allées comme et les sondages montrent ça
je pense que je pense qu'on ferait quand
même beaucoup mieux et qu'on a fait
beaucoup mieux parce que les sondages
est ce que notre jour on demandait
justement dans un sondage
ainsi nicolas sarkozy ferait mieux que
monsieur hollande 55 % des français ont
dit oui je pense qu'on ferait on ferait
beaucoup mieux parce que je pense que la
politique par exemple le fait qu'ils
aient supprimer la tva
antidélocalisation le fait qu'ils aient
supprimé le non remplacement d'un
fonctionnaire sur deux le fait qu'ils
aient remis en cause la défiscalisation
des heures supplémentaires puissent
toucher qui fait tout ceci pénalise
l'emploi donc je pense qu'on aurait fait
est qu'on ferait beaucoup mieux
néanmoins il faut bien écouter l'opinion
publique et l'opinion publique nous dit
on vous fait confiance aujourd'hui pour
vous opposer aux socialistes mais on ne
vous fait pas encore confiance forcément
pour gouverner le pays
donc on a encore du travail à l'aise et
vous ne voulez pas en 2010 est gagné par
défaut si j'ose dire moi ce que je crois
c'est qu'il faut essayer de gagner pour
être capable de gouverner donc c'est
pour ça que je suis d'accord avec ce
qu'a proposé et copé l'ump en général
c'est à dire de faire des ordonnances ce
qui n'est pas fait dans la première
année n'est pas fait après donc il faut
qu'on prépare maintenant nos
propositions
les faire connaître aux français et leur
dire clairement ce que nous ferons dans
les six mois qui viennent et ce que nous
voulons changer
c'est comme ça qu'on va gagner en
crédibilité donc la situation est d'une
extrême gravité
je suis heureux de voir que dans ma
famille politique on n'a pas triomphé
même si évident
on a été heureux de voir un grand nombre
de villes basculer l monsieur raffarin
ya quand même des gens dans votre
famille politique qui disent des choses
curieuses
par exemple hier guillaume pelletier a
dit que le fn et le ps se valaient vous
êtes d'accord avec ça
qu'est ce que vous en pensez monsieur
bussereau vous ai vu à faire et 8 pour
dire mais qu'il se taise
est-ce que voulez vous aussi vous
demander de se taire non parce que je
pense que dans un parti politique livre
comme le nôtre il faut que chacun puisse
s'exprimer et donc je pense qu'on est on
n'est pas d'accord sur le sujet moi je
ne mets pas le fn et le ps sur le même
plan mais je n'ai pas non plus
l'élection présidentielle élection
locale sur le même plan et donc il faut
il faut un peu de nuance
là ce qui est évident c'est que le ps
par ses échecs développe le front
national donc nous si on fait ce que le
front national appelle lui elle ps
c'est-à-dire son donne le sentiment
qu'on a avec le psd sympathie
naturellement on développe le front
national donc ce front républicain c'est
une machine à produire du front national
donc le l'on peut pas adhérer à cette
logique
hier monsieur léotard qui est sorti de
son long silence et que vous a dit que
françois léotard lui de fréjus temps
alors il a dit justement qu'il fallait
au contraire un front républicain est
que le ni ni ni ps ni front national
prôné par l'ump par monsieur copé par
vous même ce n'était pas la bonne
politique il pour empêcher un maire fn
d'arriver à fréjus il fallait faire ce
front républicain qu'est ce que vous en
pensez
moi je respecte beaucoup françois les
auteurs françois léotard a défendu cette
thèse depuis le début moi je pense que
sur des élections municipales il faut
une attitude avec un discernement plus
grands je constate que je pense qu'il
faut être attentif naturellement
comportement des gens à leurs
déclarations et leur attitude
mais sur le fond des choses toute
complicité avec le ps de la part de
l'ump conduit au développement du front
national et moi je veux lutter contre le
développement du front national le front
national et au nahd notre adversaire il
veut prendre notre place donc on peut
pas être avec lui en situation de torres
on est évidemment en situation
d'opposition radicale avec le front
national
mais on n'est pas là pour l'aider à se
développer en opposition avec
on est en opposition avec le front
national oui bien sûr qu'on a on a on a
vraiment éclos pour le front national
une adversité qui est une adversité
quand vous avez la possibilité de
l'empêcher d'accéder à une mairie vous
n'optez pas pour ce choix on vous retire
en troisième position on a donc on a
décidé de ne pas le faire parce que les
bacs avignon on a décidé de ne pas le
faire dévier tous ceux qui tous ceux qui
affichent une complicité avec le ps
favorise le front national aujourd'hui
la question des français contrairement à
ce que j'entends partout aujourd'hui la
question des français c'est pas le front
national la question des français c est
ce que le gouvernement est capable de
régler les problèmes de la france et
donc très souvent on vote ici l'ump la
barre front national parce qu'on veut
d'abord dit non au parti socialiste donc
la question aujourd'hui c'est est ce que
le parti socialiste est capable de
changer de politique donc on fait du
front national un phénomène exceptionnel
je regrette d'ailleurs que à l'étranger
c'est ce qui apparaît aujourd'hui je
vous rappelle 500 élus front national
quatre-vingt mille élus ump donc gardons
les proportions
ce qui compte la ville et ump oui 53
milles et sociale donc ce sont des
chiffres très importants et il est
évident aujourd'hui que la question qui
est posée à la france c'est la question
son redressement économique
c'est pas d'autres questions et tous les
autres problèmes sont la conséquence de
notre situation d'économie extrêmement
fragile donc le front national c'est un
adversaire pas d'alliance mais non plus
pas d'alliance avec le parti socialiste
qui est responsable de cette situation
certains nouveaux deux parties voulaient
faire le procès de monsieur copé à
propos des dépenses de campagne de 2012
et même ils rêvaient d'obtenir sa tête
je crois qu'on peut dire des choses
comme cela
et si le succès de l'ump se confirme
dimanche tout ça tombe à l'eau il n'y a
pas il est pas question de faire son
procès n'est pas question de se mettre
autour d'une table pour lui demander des
comptes
l'ump pas plus qu'eux
la presse plus que les observateurs ne
sont des juges et des magistrats
l'affairé devant la justice elle est
posée de réussite que la justice à son
travail
et d'ici là on n'a pas à transformer les
hommes politiques en magistrat donc la
question sera posée de savoir si nos
dirigeants dans leur ensemble sont à la
hauteur de leur tâche si on gagne les
élections la réponse est plutôt oui
donc nous verrons un peu comment les
choses se présentent mais en tout cas ce
n'est pas à nous de faire le travail des
magistrats
la justice est saisie qu'elle puisse
faire son travail normalement lundi
colas sarkozy a publié une lettre
retentissante vendredi dernier dans le
figaro
vous n'avez pensez quoi de cette lettre
très franchement au départ j'étais un
peu surpris parce que je les trouvais
naturellement prenantes gelé vu comme
quelque chose qui était profonde sa part
et j'ai vu que à deux jours du scrutin
c'était quelque chose qui m'a surpris je
note que les électeurs de droite qui
selon lui ont trouvé cette lettre qu'il
est éclatante de vérité ils ont trouvé
cette halle est positive et donc
d'évidence et une lettre qui a participé
à la mobilisation de l'électorat dit
qu'il avait aidé la mobilisation je
pense que les attaques dont a été
victime nicolas sarkozy avait créé une
inquiétude et les sympathisants nicolas
sarkozy qui ne sont pas toutes
l'opposition mais qui sont une partie de
l'opposition sont inquiets quand ils ne
voient pas nicolas sarkozy est combatif
retrouvez le sarkozy combatif ça les a
rassurés et donc je pense que c'est un
élément important mais le fond de la
faire c'est les socialistes dans nos
pâtit parce que quand on voit quelle
socialiste ressorte l'antisarkozysme
alors que ça fait deux ans qu'ils ont
battus qui devrait être passé à autre
chose qui devrait nous parler d'emploi
qui n'ouvrait par une stratégie et qui
ressorte sarkozy parce qu'ils n'ont pas
d'autre discours que l'antisarkozysme le
total de tout ça
sexe sanctions contre le ps que l'ump
devra ressortir
nicolas sarkozy est ce que pour vous est
le seul rempart face à marine le pen
prochaine présidentielle nous avons il
est beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire
il est beaucoup trop tôt pour le dire
nous avons plusieurs personnalités qui
ont la dimension pour assumer les
responsabilités d'état major
je pense je pense à la de l'express je
pense à alain juppé je pense a
naturellement à françois fillon je pense
à nicolas sarkozy et à beaucoup d'autres
et donc tout cela le moment venu on a un
dispositif de primaires nous verrons
comment les choses se présentent donc
nous choisirons le moment venu mais il
est évident que la place de nicolas
sarkozy est singulière puisque lui a
déjà fait la preuve qu'il était capable
de gouverner
donc il a déjà montré sa propre capacité
et d'une certaine manière la légitimité
de son ambition ses ambitions il ya donc
nous verrons le banc rouge c'est
semble-t-il
j'ai aussi cette intuition l'armée nous
verrons bien à bordeaux alain juppé
vous avez célébré une expérience côté
gauche tout à l'heure pour le
remplacement markham on verra là alain
juppé il est porté vers 2017 après sa
victoire à bordeaux
je pense que l'inexpérience et parfois
l'incompétence que l'on trouve dans les
sphères du pouvoir aujourd'hui en effet
appel expériences et compétences
qu'est-ce qu'ils sont deux atouts cinq
ans étudiant ça peut même être d'autres
et donc ça dépendra le moment venu
comment les choses se présentent nous
verrons ça le moment venu dans les bras
la vôtre on a l'impression personnelle
et fois elle n'est pas en question mon
ambition mais en tout cas ce que je peux
vous dire c'est à la présidentielle
quand je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
qu'il fallait pas se réjouir trop tôt
il faut se dire que c'est une élection
très satisfaisante il faut encourager
les français à repasser une deuxième
couche dimanche prochain parce qu'on a
un gouvernement de malentendants et donc
il faut considérer c'est une couche il
va falloir parce que là ils ont chanté
une gifle vous disons pas entendu la
première couche ils n'ont pas vu la
première course au volant pas senti la
première résistance une saison on
voulait dire donc pour une fois que vous
êtes plus sévère que moi cet anglais
dans le genre j'en ris mais ce qui peut
ce qui comptera pour nous le moment venu
ces deux êtres capables de reconstruire
et de vivre ces trois ans avec sérénité
mais avec gravité la situation du pays
est grave tout petits une toute petite
version question comment est-ce que vous
réagissez devant le succès des maires
ump en délicatesse avec la justice voire
qui ont été condamnés et qu'ils ont été
réélus dimanche
écoutez je ne sais pas surpris parce que
la politique c'est souvent la
compétition de l'efficacité
et c'est plus souvent dans le match
morale efficacité des gens qui affiche
l'efficacité qui peut l'emporter
donc c'est danser c'est assez décevant
pour les humanistes comme moi qui est
attaché à la valeur éthique mais je note
mes dans l'histoire je l'aï vu très
souvent que souvent les lecteurs
préfèrent quelqu'un d'efficace dont on
sait qu'il donnera des résultats plutôt
que quelqu'un qui est éthiquement
parfait mais qui n'a peut-être pas
l'énergie et de l'efficacité donc ça
s'éteint c'est un vieux débat de la
démocratie déjà platon nous parler de
cela et donc il y avait des très vieux
comme comme question je pense que
néanmoins il nous faut faire en sorte
que la valeur de l'éthique soit au
premier rang des valeurs politiques
merci des jeux perrine tarneaud arrive
donc maintenant jean pierre raffarin
pour évoquer vos ambitions personnelles
on va parler de la présidence du sénat
des élections régionales qui s'est à
nouveau face à ségolène royal sandra
circa il fut l'un des premiers à
revendiquer le droit d'inventaire des
années sarkozy
il a aussi affirmé que l'ump n'est pas
apte à gouverner une liberté de parole
que jean pierre raffarin cultive
volontairement
c'est quelqu'un qui a une forme de
bonhomie et qu'en même temps il ya
beaucoup de science politique et qu un
profil très modérée et sa norme de
rassemblement il y a une forme de
gourmandise chez lui apparaître comme
l'éternel empêcheurs de penser en rond
le sénateur n'a pas renoncé à jouer sa
partition à l'ump et se positionne même
comme un sage au sein de son parti
en mal de leadership souvent le premier
ministre l'échec tivement est à son
apogée puis quelques années après
il est passé jean pierre raffarin non
seulement n'est nommé actif et il a un
avenir politique probablement s'ils le
souhaitent
la seule question que l'on peut se poser
c'est quelle est la volonté de jean
pierre raffarin d'imprimer un rythme et
d'avoir une ambition
alors quel avenir politique pour jean
pierre raffarin va-t-il continuer à
jouer l'éternel médiateur à droite
tentera-t-il de rester au centre du jeu
dans la perspective de 2017 ou plus
probable envisage-t-il de récupérer le
poitou charentes
l'ancien président de la région ne
résisteraient pas à l'idée d'affronter
ségolène royal en 2015
le mp le rock au coeur des régions
l'année prochaine il ya vingt-deux
régions il y en a qu'une qui est gérée
j'ai bien géré par l'épée donc si jean
pierre raffarin peut nous reprendre la
présidence de la région poitou-charentes
bravo à moins que jean pierre raffarin
ne rêvent toujours de présider le sénat
est de rejouer le duel de 2008 avec
gérard larcher qui est déjà candidat en
octobre prochain
une autre bataille au goût de revanche
alors on voit donc en différant michel
j'espère que mon écoute mon épouse n'a
pas regardé cette émission pascal va
s'inquiéter des ambitions on la salue
alors d'abord sur le sénat où les
appétits de la droite s'aiguise après ce
premier tour des élections municipales
parce qu'on peut rappeler quand même que
les grands électeurs dessinateur ce sont
les maires et les élus municipaux
vous y croyez au basculement du sénat
alors disons que nous je suis sûr de la
victoire en 2017
14h14 2017 nous gagnerons parce que la
génération de ces municipales va faire
deux générations deux sénateurs donc
2017 c'est gagner maintenant déjà qu'ils
résultats du premier tour 2014 ça reste
incertain on verra dimanche
ça reste incertain puisque les
socialistes pour devient possible alors
que vous étiez plus négatif il ya
quelques semaines en plus
il faut attendre un certain nombre de
grandes villes qui par exemple si on
gagne brive on change des choses si on
gagne angoulême on change les choses
donc ce sont des départements pour les
celles qui sont renouvelables pour
lesquelles on avait pas d'espoir très
fort et que maintenant on peut avoir des
espoirs donc on verra ce qu'il faudra le
moment venu c'est qu'on ait une
stratégie au fonds pour sauver le sénat
pour rénover le sénat pour changer le
sénat sonder l'ill et mais bien sûr on
voit bien que le sénat est en cause
aujourd'hui le gouvernement le
marginalise on a l'appui cependant le
sentiment qu'une forme d'un d'absence et
surtout d'amérique mais ça c'est pas de
notre fait
c'est parce qu'il ya eu un partage du
pouvoir qui n'a pas correspondu à un
partage du projet est donc un certain
nombre de groupes politiques les
écologistes et communistes ont participé
au partage du pouvoir mais que le moment
venu quand il ya un texte à voter ne
vote pas donc partage du pouvoir sans
partage du projet il ya le clash est au
fond il ya cette forme d'impuissance et
au fond les socialistes n'ont jamais eu
pour le sénat une considération
extrêmement puissante on se souvient des
déclarations de monsieur jospin
donc on a besoin d' un bicamérisme en
france on a besoin d'avoir une assemblée
qui soit une assemblée d'une
intelligence tempéré d'une assemblée qui
puisse modérer un peu l'assemblée
nationale mais qui puisse en même temps
pensé à long terme
on a besoin d'un nouvel élan pour le
sénat et donc le moment venu il va
falloir travailler sur ce projet il
s'agit pas de prendre la place des
socialistes il s'agit vraiment d'avoir
une autre vision
une autre ambition une autre force
pensionnaires on sent ça vous tient à
coeur et que vous avez envie ça me
projet phare
je souhaite qu'elle soit portée
quelqu'un d'aussi à quelqu'un s'il ya
quelqu'un de meilleur que moi pour
porter ce projet qu'ils le portent
mais ce que je souhaite c'est qu'il soit
porté et donc il y ce qui est important
c'est qu'il y ait une ambition qui une
force et je pense qu'on peut pas refaire
le sénat du passé il faut aujourd'hui à
nouveau sénat avec une nouvelle ambition
donc on verra les états c'est une
personnalité qui ne semblait présent ce
scénario on verra bien c'est aux
sénateurs
moi je ne suis pas candidat en tant que
tel j'ai été candidat qu'une fois je
pensais que cet été ça faisait partie
et donc ça mais moi c'est une affaire
qui est derrière moi maintenant je
regarde toujours devant
donc si je peux servir à quelque chose
je le ferai mais je ne suis pas dans
cette logique là très franchement mon
sentiment quand on a été premier
ministre
on est dans une état d'esprit est un
état d intéresser au fond moi je j'aime
la france j'aime mieux la france que la
politique donc ce qui compte pour moi
c'est qu'on ait des institutions fortes
ce qui compte pour moi c'est qu'on
travaille les questions de fond comme le
chômage comme l'immigration comme l'a
très bien skié pas quand même deux
candidats aux jeunes l ex connaître mais
je me reconnais maintenant je ne pense
pas rien parce qu'ils se libèrent à la
tête du sénat puisque jean pierre bel a
annoncé qu'il ne serait pas candidat au
renouvellement de son mandat vous avez
été surpris j'étais surpris j'étais
surpris c'est quelqu'un pour qui j'ai de
l'estimé
j'étais j'étais surpris je m'attendais
pas à cette décision vous l'interprétez
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas c'est peut
être personnel c'est peut-être lié à la
situation de son groupe politique tu as
dit concurrence interne que je n'en sais
rien en tout cas je ne peux pas dire que
c'était un président qui était ou
désagréables ou insuffisant il a été un
président du sénat que je respecte que
j'ai respecté donc je n'ai pas j'aurai
je ferais autrement que lui mais il est
je crois très important dans cette
maison de savoir juger aussi les
personnes avec leur vraie qualité est la
sienne et existantes
votre avenir aussi peut-être dans la
région poitou charentes est ce que vous
confirmez que vous aimeriez bien
affronter ségolène royal aux élections
régionales de 2015
là aussi pour être très franc je sais
c'est pas moi c'est pas mon ambition
tout le monde me prête ça pourquoi pas
ce que j'ai dit je répète que je pense
que nous allons gagner massivement les
régionales c'est une de mes déceptions
un peu historique
la région n'est pas un mandat de
l'enracinement on a eu cinq élections
mais en 92 ans 98 86 92 98 la gauche est
au pouvoir et la droite gagne
massivement avec ses trois élections
2004 2010 la droite est au pouvoir la
gauche calme massivement
on peut d'ores et déjà annoncer une
victoire massive de l'opposition aux
élections régionales c'est pas un mandat
d'enracinement
ce sont des midterm fait donc et elle
bascule un peu tout de la même façon
donc quelle que soit la personnalité et
d'une certaine manière plus la
personnalité est une personnalité
explosé connu plus sa sanction est forte
surtout si ségolène royal rentrer au
gouvernement d'ailleurs ne sera
peut-être pas quand ils adorent
régionale puisqu'elle serait amené à
occuper un grand ministère maintenant je
vois les dernières rumeurs cela je vois
le tas du gouvernement actuellement je
pense que et son intuition d'une part et
son énergie d'autre part ne pourrait
être utile noël peut être une des
solutions pour relancer ce gouvernement
c'est peut-être en tout cas elle ne
manque pas de qualités pour cela
en tout cas par rapport aux défauts que
l'on peut constater l orée des qualités
complémentaires vous annoncer la
victoire de l'opposition aux
sénatoriales aux régionales vous avez
juste un doute pour 2017 et je comprends
bien ce qu'on va bien sûr un bien sûr
parce que de toute façon et regardons
les choses historiquement c'est grosso
modo du 48 52
les institutions sont très très forts
dans la vème république moi je me
souviens quand jacques chirac père est
la dissolution tout le monde le dit
jacques chirac est finie méfiez-vous
le président de la république en france
n'est jamais fini et soyons très
attentifs à ça la fonction la vème
république
elle donne au président une force
institutionnel très puissante aucun
président peut toujours un moment ou un
autre bon dire notre président actuel
est en situation d'extrême faiblesse une
impopularité massive
ça ne veut pas dire que dans d'ici trois
ans une nouvelle donne une situation
internationale
compte tenu de l'état de gravité de la
société française il peut se passer des
soubresauts violents brutaux je le
crains je suis très inquiet sur la
situation du pays et donc je ne sais pas
quelle serait la situation à l'issue
d'un certain nombre d'événements dans
notre pays donc je suis d'une extrême
prudence
est ce que je sais c'est que la fonction
institutionnelle n'est pas une fonction
légère on va revenir à cette semaine
avec la visite en france du président
chinois à une visite très protocolaire
fastueuse destinée que finalement la
relation franco chinoise va bien va
mieux que lors du précédent quinquennat
ou ç'avait été un peu difficile parfois
avec nicolas sarkozy les deux dernières
années du quinquennat sarkozy les
relations étaient stabilisés il ya eu
une période en 2008 difficile l'occasion
des jeux olympiques mais par la suite
notamment pour la préparation du g20
la relation entre roger now et nicolas
sarkozy était une relation de confiance
il s'était l'année
apprivoiser le voyage de françois
hollande a plutôt été un succès en chine
et celui de jean marc ayrault également
donc la visite que le président français
ne connaissais pas du tout la chine
c'est être absolument absolument est
donc là il a fait beaucoup d'efforts
pour s'installer dans le paysage
institutionnel
le premier ministre est allé plusieurs
jours a signé un certain nombre de
partenariats
donc ils ont fait les efforts pour bien
montrer une bonne volonté française et
donc le président chinois rang je dirais
la politesse avec cette visite d'état je
crois que ça va il n'y avait plus d'une
centaine de contrats qui était en
préparation dont il a fallu en
sélectionner un certain nombre pourrait
signer de manière publique
il ya une vraie coopération qui se fait
je pense que la relation entre la chine
et la france est de bonne qualité
je pense qu'elle est stabilisé
aujourd'hui et donc qu'on peut avoir
confiance dans ce bien là on sent que là
effectivement la france ne veut pas
froisser les chinois aux points de
desserte est totalement la question des
droits de l'homme je ne suis pas sûr
qu'elles soient désertés elle n'est pas
politiquement utilisé mais elle n'est
pas forcément déserté elle est en
général toujours abordé mais
naturellement ce que souhaitent les
chinois c'est qu'on les prévienne contre
qu'on parle avec eux et qu'on n'en fasse
pas une exploitation politique il ne
souhaite pas que on donne à
l'occidentale des leçons occidental à
travers des médias occidentaux
donc ils veulent qu'on respecte völler
leur diversité et culturel du style et
donc mais quand on est face à eux on a
des discussions approfondies j'ai vu des
listes de dissidents qui était transmise
aux dirigeants chinois dans le passé il
ya un certain nombre de choses qui se
font je suis sûr que la diplomatie
française continue dans cette voie est
ce qu'on nous a pas fait croire que la
prospérité économique allait favoriser
la liberté d'expression par exemple en
chine ce qui n'est pas le cas du tout
vous le savez aujourd'hui il faudrait
faut nuancer tout ça parce que si vous
regardez bien twitter enfin le web au
mois juin contre 8 beau en chine
je vois qu'il ya quand même beaucoup
d'expressions il ya plusieurs centaines
de millions de gens qui sont sur bebo
est certes il ya des messages qui sont
effacés
mais les chinois sont très créatifs pour
détourner les procédures je pense que la
société civile chinoise est en marche
elle bouge et la jeunesse j'avais à
twitter est interdite mais je reçois sur
web os des gens qui me félicitent pour
des messages sur twitter se veut dire
que twitter est interdite mais qui
trouve le moyen souvent l'écouté twitter
donc je pense que la société civile est
très active et qu'elle s'exprime plus
librement qu'on le dit au fond la
liberté totale si on ne fait pas de
politique c'est ça la règle donc que dès
qu'on touche à la politique qui a là un
certain nombre de risques mais sur le
fond des choses c'est une société qui
peut s'exprimer de manière très libre
sur bien des sujets voilà pour cette
visite d'état du président chinois
jean ping je ne sais pas si je prononce
bien sûr c'est très bien il aurait dit à
poutine
vous et moi nous avons des caractères
très semblable ça fait un peu peur faut
se méfier parce que s'ils s'étaient
traduits en russe ou en chinois et en
français à moscou mais
je pense que c'est pas tout à fait vrai
bien sûr où le président xi jinping a
beaucoup de rondeur de l'empirisme a
beaucoup de pragmatisme et qu'il a une
communication non verbale assez forte
alors que ce putin est assez glaciale
avec des yeux au laser
donc c'est pas de ces deux formes de
personnalités qui me paraissent quand
même elle différente il ya un côté un
peu plus latins chez cegid pigs les
mains avec l'intermédiaire de mon repos
psychologique 50 aussi en politique
so lu ment mais en tout cas je suis je
lui souhaite la bienvenue en france
merci merci vous allez suivre cette
visite d'état de très près vous y êtes
même associé bien sûr jean pierre
raffarin
merci d'avoir été avec nous aujourd'hui
demain donc à perrine nous accueillons
alain vidalies ce nom que le ministre
chargé des relations avec le parlement à
demain très vite